[Musique]
la province du rhône ain à 900 km au sud
de pékin c'est là que tout a commencé il
ya trois ans
des villageois tous atteints du sida
accepté pour la première fois de
témoigner devant notre caméra
ces images allaient faire scandale parce
qu'elle prouve est ce que les autorités
tentaient de cacher depuis des années
près d'un million de personnes
contaminées à cause de seraing non
stérile de centrifugeuses collective un
commerce du sang à grande échelle
quelques mois plus tard les autorités
réagissent et enfin en lançant un
programme dead
trois ans après ong journalistes sont
toujours interdits de séjour dans les
villages du rhône ain
à l'entrée du village mon guide m'attend
malgré le risque d'être repérés en plein
jour il veut absolument que je filme ce
champs parsemés de monticules de terre
ce sont les membres du village
des dizaines de tombes anonymes qui font
ressurgir les visages désespérés qui me
hante depuis trois ans
il y attendent le malade qu'il devenait
impossible de cacher la vérité
une amitié val et les choses ont
commencé à changer
c'est grâce aux médias qui ont révélé la
faire mais aussi aux malades eux mêmes
se sont mobilisés
si on a un proverbe qui dit que seuls
les bébés qui leur ont dit si tu ne ris
pas tu n'auras rien
selon mon guide il resterait encore 600
personnes séropositives dans le village
seulement un tiers d'entre elles sont
pris en charge médicalement par les
autorités
total il a quel âge
28 ans je fasse rire
taille était là lui aussi
oui ça fait un angle
et comment il l'a attrapée
comment il attrapé le virus il a vendu
son ensemble
moi je ne peux plus travailler
maintenant
ça fait un an qu'il est malade
maintenant et il va de plus en plus mal
ça fait des mois qu'il ne peut plus
lever et c'est moi qui doit nourrir
maintenant alors bien sûr je peux plus
aller travailler
j'ai soigné chômé hier oui bien sûr mais
on n'a plus de médicaments maintenance
on achète des petites bouteilles qu'on
utilise en perfusion mais quand on n'a
plus d'argent on a plus de médicaments
il y à des médicaments contre la fièvre
et si là aussi il ya des antibiotiques
aussi
mais c'est surtout du glucose qu'on a
pour les perfusions
les eaux et son voisin yen sont morts
depuis ma dernière visite
ils n'ont jamais eu accès aux
médicaments distribués depuis que le
scandale du sang éclaté et encore moins
à ce bâtiment le dispensaire flambant
neuf inauguré il ya deux ans
même s'il est situé tout près de leur
maison joe et sa femme tous les deux
séropositifs depuis 1997 s'y rendent
rarement ils n'ont plus confiance
la santé du bébé n'est pas très bonne
il a souvent de la fièvre l'île
d'hatteras beaucoup de rhume
leur fils aîné après notre passage dans
le village lui aussi est séropositif
ses parents n'ont aucune preuve mais ils
sont persuadés qu'ils aient été
contaminés au moment de l'accouchement
c'est notre unique enfant
on fait très attention quand on peut
avoir qu'un enfant
nous avait dit à l'époque qu'avec une
mère séropositive
c'était mieux les faire naître l'enfant
avec une césarienne
il disait que c'était plus sûr pour la
sécurité de l'enfant
je prends ça
c'est quoi comme médicament
c'est de la médecine occidentale elle
est fabriquée ou
je crois que c'est à shanghai mais je ne
suis pas très sûr mais il n'ya rien
écrit dessus
non
je ne vois aucun nom sur l'emballage
et comment tu dois l'épreuve
je ne sais pas combien de fois prends-tu
les cachets chaque jour deux fois par
jour
les cachets de death and who s'attaque
vraiment l'estomac
on devient très nauséeux on ne peut plus
manger
cela fait maintenant deux ans que le
gouvernement a remplacé les
prescriptions de glucose par des vrais
médicaments anti sida
mais là encore la confiance est
difficile à établir
plus de la moitié des patientes
abandonné le traitement à cause d'effets
secondaires terrible nous explique notre
guide
le plus souvent la peau et le visage
enfoui le malade perd la vue ou alors il
a des maux de tête terrible
gens sans soutien médical ont pris peur
ils ont pensé que c'était du poison
beaucoup ont très vite abandonné le
traitement et jeter les médicaments
mais le plus terrible est que certains
charlatans ou vraiment utiliser du
poison comme l'arsenic
on peut les gens ils le mélanger avec
d'autres substances et faisait sniffer
aux malades se mélange
bien sûr cela te faisais couler le nez
les yeux le charlatan tu disais alors
que le virus sortait du corps par telles
armes
chez nous il ya une personne qui est
morte empoisonnée comme ça
lyle
achats this comment bâtir
il ne va pas très bien
symptôme at il dit
il a souvent de la fièvre coca
notre argent c'est pour lui tu sais
on n'ose pas lui donner nos médicaments
anti sida
[Musique]
un enfant qui a le sida pour ses parents
c'est une douleur vraiment insupportable
les adultes finalement c'est pas si
grave si on attrape russie là
mais comment on fait avec un enfant qui
a cette maladie
moi je trouve que l'état doit maintenant
trouver le moyen d'avoir des médicaments
pour les enfants
à la nuit tombée nous retrouvons en fin
de chaîne il nous avait accueilli chez
lui lors de notre visite précédente
250 mhz ans plus tard il fait
aujourd'hui figure de miraculé dans le
village
il ya trois ans quand tu es venu on
était tous complètement désespéré au
village on avait l'impression qu'avec
cette maladie il n'y avait plus qu'à
attendre la mort personne n'a les biens
à l'époque chaîne avait été le premier à
oser témoigner
grâce à son courage les autres
villageois rassurer étaient venus aussi
se confier les uns après les autres
c'était d'un slogan des autorités à
l'époque un slogan de vos dirigeants
oui il me disait que c'était un honneur
de vendre son sens
regarde je suis couvert de champignons
aujourd'hui encore chaîne vale un cran
au dessus dans la critique pour lui tout
ce qui a été fait ici depuis trois ans
n'est qu'une politique de façade
au dispensaire il n'y a même pas de
médicaments contre le rhume actuellement
ce n'est pas qu'il n'ait rien mais il ne
les distribue pas ses médicaments c'est
encore un gros mensonge pour tromper des
supérieurs hiérarchiques et continue à
cacher la réalité aux peuples
quand une délégation d autorité
supérieure vient enquêter tout le monde
se tait sur la situation réelle
comme par hasard dès qu'une délégation
arrivent les distribution de médicaments
reprennent immédiatement
à 100 km de là un autre village touché
par l'épidémie
il est plus facile d'accès car cela fait
à peine un an que les premiers cas de
sida et ont été découverts
il y a eu beaucoup moins de décès que
dans le village de chaîne
c'est votre famille qui est touché
oui ils sont tous malades
combien de personnes
mon fils ma belle fille et mon gendre
et c'est tous en vendant leur sang oui
tous ont vendu leur sang
madame billet c'est aujourd'hui que ses
enfants sont condamnés
mais ces jours ci c'est son fils aîné
qui est l'objet de toutes ses attentions
son état se dégrade d'heure en heure
ouais
non il ne peut plus parler
il ne peut plus bouger non plus
sauvian ça fait quatre ou cinq jours
qu'il ne mange plus
il a juste réussi à boire deux petites
bouteilles d'eau
mais dans cet état vous ne l'oubliez pas
l'hôpital
on n'a pas d'argent pour l'hôpital
on ne peut pas payer les médicaments
on attend la mort à la maison
moi j'ai été demandé de l'aide aux
officiels du village juste un peu dead
ils m'ont carrément insulté ils m'ont
dit comme ça vous avez vendu votre sang
et maintenant vous vous plaignez aux
autorités chinoises
de la haine
ils nous méprisent horriblement pour eux
dès qu'ils s'aperçoivent qu'on a le sida
c'est va te faire voir c'est vraiment de
la haine
dans le village tous les donneurs de
sang et leurs enfants subi un test de
dépistage l'été dernier les parents
séropositifs disent n'avoir jamais reçu
les résultats pour leurs enfants une
information troublante quand on sait
qu'aucun médicament anti sida pour les
enfants n'est disponible en chine pour
les villageois c'est une raison
supplémentaire de se méfier
on a peur que le gouvernement ou des
laboratoires nous utilisent pour tester
des médicaments on a peur de devenir des
cobayes
moi j'ai rempli les conditions pour
prendre ces antirétroviraux
mais je n'ai aucune confiance
je ne prends donc aucun traitement aussi
pour en savoir plus sur ces médicaments
distribués par l'état nous nous rendons
à shanghai au siège de lusine des sano
l'une des rares entreprises
pharmaceutiques autorisées à produire
des médicaments anti sida en chine
à notre grande surprise le pdg de lusine
nous confirme ce que nous savions déjà
sur ses médicaments
les effets secondaires sont elles avec
nos combinaisons de molécules que les
malades abandonne le traitement
n'arrive pas à en supporter la douleur
on n'a pas le droit de produire de
meilleures combinaisons de molécules à
cause des brevets internationaux
on doit respecter
et je ne vois pas comment cette
situation pourra changer dans les
prochaines années
contrairement à des pays comme l'inde ou
le brésil la chine se refuse à copier
des médicaments plus performant mais
protégé par des brevets internationaux
encore plus étonnant 90% de la
production de dessins anneaux est
destinée à l'exportation
en clair les malades chinois ne sont pas
encore une priorité
en 2005 le programme de l'état prévoit
des médicaments anti sida sont vingt à
trente mille personnes c'est chiant
mais pour notre usine cela représente
très peu
j'ai pourrions produire beaucoup plus
vingt mille malades traités sur près
d'un million recensés officiellement
dans tout le pays
c'est peu face à la pandémie que
craignent toujours les militants de la
première heure
nous avons retrouvé waneux rail à pékin
le plus connu des activistes anti sida
en chine
aujourd'hui son organisation est
reconnue officiellement mais il ya trois
ans lors de notre première rencontre
moynier rail agissez encore dans la
clandestinité
nous l'avions suivi accompagnant un
couple de paysans du rhône ain atteints
du sida dans leurs démarches auprès des
ministères
quelques jours après nous avoir parlé
moyens rails allait être arrêté
en
prison j'ai été obligé d'écrire une
lettre cetto critique dans laquelle j'ai
reconnaissait avoir rendu public un
document confidentiel
j'avais enfreint la loi sa gelée reconnu
le gouvernement a expliqué qu'il m'avait
relâché par mansuétude
c'est ce qu'ils disent
le militant sera en fait de relâcher au
bout d'un mois grâce à une mobilisation
internationale considérable
[Musique]
aujourd'hui sa notoriété le protège et
lui permet de recueillir 15 fois plus de
financements qu'avant
pour lui seule solution pour ralentir la
progression de l'épidémie éliminé une
bonne fois pour toutes le commerce du
sang en chine
il existe encore des failles dans le
circuit du sang elles sont moins
nombreuses qu'avant mais elle existe
toujours
avec toutes ces personnes contaminées si
on ne maîtrise pas mieux ses failles le
risque de contamination pour la
population sera aussi important qu'avec
le commerce du sang je pense qu'il vaut
mieux dans ces conditions interdire de
manière plus claire la banque de sang il
faut que les dons de sang soit
uniquement bénévoles
les failles dans le circuit du sang lee
tienne si peu en parler en connaissance
de cause et il travaille depuis plus de
20 ans dans un centre de transfusion du
100 à 400 km de pékin un témoin capital
dans le dossier à charge lancée par les
médias contre son administration
pendant plusieurs années il a vu des
poches de sang périmés et non testés
transfusé à grande échelle dans sa ville
lui aussi a été puni par ses supérieurs
pour avoir voulu tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé contre un projet ni prochain
mes supérieurs étaient radicalement
opposée à ce que je parle
[Musique]
ce qu'ils ont fait est vraiment trop
grave
après la diffusion de mon interview à la
télévision centrale l'été dernier
l'état a commencé à accorder de
l'attention aux victimes contaminées
lors de transfusions
mais ici localement ils ne veulent pas
en entendre parler
tasha dif 1 il a pour car en fait c'est
à cause d'eux que ces contaminations
étudiants
litlle n 6 a longtemps hésité avant de
nous parler mais il a décidé de le faire
pour sauver des vies dit-il
partout le scandale a éclaté la
hiérarchie responsable des
contaminations est encore en poste
impuni mais ce n'est pas le pire
ouah monsieur d'un travail un trail
hunan et notre centre a réalisé ces
jours derniers que tu sens périmés avait
été encore utilisé il a même été
transfusé et aux soignants comment la
gestion de notre centre at elle pu
autoriser ça comment cette transfusion
at elle pu avoir lieu c'est une histoire
qui vient tout juste de se passer
tout bientôt vingt titres et a alors
selon vous est ce qu'on peut dire que
les transfusions sont sûrs de nos jours
ce sit-in
michaud h aux jeunes mannequins dont
la dernière fois que l'it yens 6,7
exprimé dans les médias chinois c'était
l'été dernier
[Musique]
depuis il est privé de salaire
retour dans le rhône ain la région la
plus touchée par l'épidémie de sida
probablement déjà plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de morts et selon l'unicef au
moins 78 mille orphelins du sida
ces enfants privés de tout et parfois
atteint eux-mêmes par la maladie sont au
coeur du combat de l'ide année de sa
petite ong
moi j'ai été contaminé en 1990 et depuis
votre fils n'a jamais été testée c'est
ça
et elle a 10 ans
il paraît qu'il demandait 300 yuans pour
le test ses 1 300 yuans pour le test de
dépistage
oui mais j'ai pas voulu pays acp ils
t'ont demandait de payer parce qu'en
fait ce n'était pas un test obligatoire
c'était un test individuel
identifier et recenser les orphelins du
sida mais aussi les enfants qui sont
condamnés à le devenir pour chacun de
ses protégés li dan va ensuite trouvé un
parrain qui s'engagera à les aider
jusqu'à la fin de leur scolarité
ceux dont les enfants montent le plus ce
n'est pas seulement d'argent bon ça
c'est la base
ils ont aussi besoin d'une aide
psychologique et de compréhension
souvent ce n'est pas seulement par
manque d'argent qu'ils ne vont plus à
l'école
et qu'ils ne voient plus clairement en
quoi l'école peut leur être utile
si tu veux aider il faut aussi mettre en
place un soutien social
il ya encore quelques mois li dan avait
une école qui lui permettait
d'accueillir une vingtaine d'enfants
regarde on a récupéré sa fière mais tous
les ordinateurs sont vides ligne à plus
de disques durs ce qui s'est passé
l'année dernière au mois de juillet
notre école a été fermée les autorités
ont tout confisqué
car il avait peur qu'on utilise sai
après cette histoire on s'est dit que
c'était bien de mettre un drapeau rouge
au mur on a pensé qu'il serait content
ceux d'en haut
et on espère qu'ils comprendront un jour
que ce qu'on fait c'est pour la chine
même si on pouvait aider dix mille
orphelins ce ne serait pas encore assez
grâce à un site internet mis en place
l'année dernière ils sont plus de 300
orphelins du sida avoir trouvé un
parrain et donateurs disséminés dans
toute la chine mais aussi au japon en
allemagne ou aux états unis
prochain objectif pour l'équipe de lead
and si les autorités le permettent
l'ouverture d'une école pouvant
accueillir 500 enfants
[Musique]
une goutte d'eau temps qu'en chine les
autorités se refuseront à affronter la
réalité de l'épidémie en face
elle